un père célèbre caractériel et absent et
un fils écrasé par sa personnalité c'est
un film aime ton père et pourtant les
deux acteurs principaux gérard et
guillaume depardieu donne pas ce long
métrage une réalité poignante l'histoire
d'un manque d'amour réglé dans un face à
face violent
le reportage de dominique poncet et jean
christophe duclos est ce que tu aimes
les enfants ça recommence
tu vas me répondre
et toi tu te défends ce jeu
c'est l'histoire d'un fils qui fut mal
aimé par un père trop célèbre est trop
absente d'un fils devenus adultes tant
bien que mal et qui va kidnapper ce père
pour tenter de lui extorquer des
explications et peut-être enfin un peu
d'amour en écrivant son film le
réalisateur jacoberger voulait évoquer
ses relations avec son propre père un
écrivain connu
pur hasard ça ressemble est étonnamment
à ce qu'a vécu gérard et guillaume
depardieu est donc c'est vrai que je me
suis dit bon c'est extraordinaire il ya
un père et un fils qui pourrait incarner
dans mon film le père et le fils et la
coïncidence me paraissait tellement
magnifique que je les tente et c'est
formidable
il l'attend et il en dit oui est ce que
tu t'es jamais demandé pourquoi je me
défoncer même mu est et le fer avec
gérard justement et nous nous amuser
avec ça avec cette histoire là et
d'aller au bout c'est un pote regard on
se connaît tellement qu'il n'y avait pas
de problème de comédiens entre
guillemets qui est qui et qui sont une
des acteurs qui a qui sont là pour
justifier leur leurs salaires
exorbitants nous on était là pour
essayer d'aller vers une épure total la
plus souvent a plutôt sont capables et
puis ainsi jeté dessus
je devenu comme toi bien une merde une
colère des méchancetés
c'est un territoire à certains enfants
se souvient pas toujours dit ou presque
universel parce que tous les tous les
fils ont ce problème donc là un problème
de légitimité finale je voulais juste te
ressembler président camille toi
universel le film l'est évidemment par
son sujet mais s'il tout ce temps c'est
que deux comédiens lyon en plus apporté
le plus authentique de même